hey everybody welcome to live-streaming
with Jessie today we're gonna start new
projects and we're gonna use react 16
which just came out recently what was it
last week it was pretty recently so
there's some cool stuff in react 16 I
haven't even gone through all the new
stuff yet so we'll definitely be
learning about that together we use
create react app just like we did for
the last project and we'll probably end
up using Redux and react router as well
so some new stuff definitely haven't
done Redux before on the stream so
that'll be cool and then some of the new
react 16 stuff we'll be using I want to
show you a kind of a preview of what the
end result is going to be and and then
we'll get started so this is definitely
starting from scratch you can see my
terminal here there's nothing I've done
nothing - to set this up yet other than
have node and NPM and yarn installed on
my machine other than that it's pretty
much from scratch so let me check I have
some comments here in the live chat
okay so Shay says congrats on your
completing your Redux project I hope
you're feeling better today how you
doing okay so a few of your asking how
how I'm doing so if you saw my tweet
yesterday
so yesterday I didn't stream so sorry
about that I intended the stream but I
saw a doctor in the morning who went
over my MRI result so last we got an MRI
dad to inject some fluid into my wrist
and then do the MRI and basically they
could tell that in my wrist
there's the
section of your wrist that has like this
triangular formation of ligaments and it
holds some bones in place and so those
ligaments in my wrist are torn so that's
what's been wrong with my wrist since
what sometime in July I think I know
I've complained about it several times
on the strain so anyway so that's what's
wrong with my wrist I went to go see a
surgeon yesterday afternoon but
unfortunately I drove up from where I am
to place near Pittsburgh and drove all
the way there and found out that they
don't take my insurance so I have to
wait now until November until that
doctor is in Ohio because if that same
doctor sees me in Ohio my insurance will
work but if I see that doctor at another
state it will not work so I don't know I
guess that's just how it is but it was a
waste of a trip and I missed my
livestream so disappointed about that
but so I'll probably end up having to
have surgery on it at some point the
doctor that I talked to yesterday
morning said it should just be like
really small incisions so hopefully that
works out all right
said if I decide not to get surgery
it'll be okay it'll just hurt and then
eventually I'll get arthritis so I
figure surgery is probably the way to go
especially if I plan on typing on a
keyboard for the rest of my life all
right so enough enough about the wrist
but I appreciate all the concern that
that you all have shown on Twitter and
in here and everything so all right I
got some new people in the live chat so
welcome thanks for joining and all right
Blake just submitted his first PR
awesome congratulations okay
all right so let's get started let me
I'm gonna start this and we'll do we're
gonna do 25 minutes of coding well we're
not really gonna code that much at first
we're gonna be doing some commands on
the command line to get it set up we're
going to do that for about 25 minutes
that's going to include me going over
what the the project requirements are
and then we'll take a five-minute break
do question-answer we're going to do at
least two sessions of coding maybe three
and we're going to work on this probably
not everyday I got some other projects
going on as well so we're gonna switch
it up we're going to go back to project
one do some updates but whenever I get a
chance I do want to come back to this
and do this project so there's not
there's not a hard deadline on this
project but it's something that I think
that it does need updated so I'm just
going to work on it as I as I can okay
so this is the objective here last year
so quite last summer so the summer of
2016 I spent working on this this
bulletin so our old University bulletin
was a Word document sent by email so
this is definitely an upgrade from that
it allows us to put in we put in videos
a lot more pictures just a lot more
content in general without having to
have this really giant word document
easier to handle attachments so it
definitely benefits also there's now a
record of everything that's ever been in
the bulletin and it's all searchable so
our project basically is going to pull
from the WordPress API like we did with
with project one so it's gonna pull
posts from the WordPress API and display
them we have two different display
options well actually more than two so
we have this grid view or the list view
we also have a print view because a lot
of people missed that they didn't
the word document so I added the print
UN basically vice-presidents this stuff
are used to having their secretaries
print out the bulletin forum and put it
on their desk so I got some calls from
secretaries administrative assistants
that we're asking hey I want to be able
to print this out so that's why I did
the print view also we have the classic
mode which was put in there for people
who are nostalgic for the old style and
this is pretty much as an exact replica
as I could get of the old bulletin it's
the same font and so you know the word
doc mint style so basically those are
the views so it's going to have four
different views it's gonna have a place
to submit announcements and that
includes a file upload which we've done
before so no big deal we can filter by
date we have all the you know categories
that we can filter by we're gonna have a
Help section which right now just has
some some text and some embedded YouTube
videos that I made and that's that's
about it it does have a an infinite
scroll function so you keep scrolling
down it just keeps loading new bulletin
posts so anyway that's that those are
the requirements things that will change
will definitely go with a new look like
we did with the Resource Center so we'll
have the new logo you know the white
header up here one thing that will be
different is it you know the sidebar is
always open on large screens so this
school I do want to redo this once I
redo this and react I think it would be
really cool to also redo this in react
native so that's a possibility
not sure if I could convince my boss
that that's really a priority but it
would be cool if we could do it the
other requirement is and this is the big
deal that's been giving me kind of a
headache right so it was decided that
you would need to login to
be able to see this but we did a survey
and users so it's just this an internal
site so users here at the University did
not want to have to remember another
password to login so I set up a password
list login system where if they put in
their University email address they will
get an email they click the link in the
email it logs them in and then it saves
the login credentials and local storage
and that will persist unless they choose
to log out or empty you know their their
local storage and their browser somehow
for a year they'd stay logged in but the
problem has been it for some reason some
you know some users do empty out their
local storage frequently and that's why
they have to keep logging in but some
users seem to have to log in way more
frequently than once a year so it's been
kind of annoying to them and I in some
cases I've been able to find why it does
that but it's kind of it's difficult I
have to actually go around to each
computer do troubleshooting that's and
there's not really been one common issue
so that's something that I'd really like
to I'd like to find another way to have
people log in without having to put in a
password so some sort of password this
log in the university is at the end of
this month they're supposed to implement
a single sign-on system it'd be great if
I can integrate it with that and that's
part of the reason why I want to
redesign this because if I'm gonna go
into this right now this is just jQuery
it's not react if I'm gonna go in and
make major changes to how the login
system works then I don't want to mess
around with all that jQuery which I'm
sure is probably a mess I mean I I made
it all so it's my own fault but I don't
want to go back in and mess with it I'd
rather just redo it now as react with
react and then that way when we
implement the system I can try to
integrate it into there I still I need
to talk to the people in the ITB
Department that are in charge of that
and and see what's possible or I'm not
even sure how they're doing their their
single sign-on I don't know if it's like
LDAP system or Active Directory so I
have to I still have to find out some
more things so we may not have to do our
own login system hopefully we can just
use that system but for now we don't
really have to worry about that we'll
just build out the UI pull in the the
posts from the WordPress API and it
shouldn't be too hard all the big
decisions are pretty are made already
right all you know how the UI works all
the views so I usually when I start a
project I don't think it'll be too hard
but we'll see we'll see how it goes all
right so first things first and also
once we get to the end I want to go over
a few pull requests I've got in so try
not to let me forget that when we do our
final question and answer session at the
end I'll start out by going over some of
the pool requests so let's go into my
projects folder that's where I keep
everything and let's uh we have create
react app installed right let's bring up
the documentation first so that everyone
can see what we're doing and can follow
along
so let's fine there we go react up
okay
I wonder if I need to update create
react that I don't know so I'm gonna do
oops
I don't know if I've ever done this with
your anthea is it update now I can't
remember
well back and forth from NPM and yarn
it's
coffee in pace whoops I didn't need the
coffee and taste that part okay all
right this is what I wanted to copy I
think I have this maybe I didn't have it
installed globally
all right good thing I did that
okay cool all right so now we'll run
create react app let me make this a
little bit bigger so everybody can see
it and it's call this bulletun react
okay so that's step one well really step
two step one was install create react
app globally we do it globally right
because we haven't even made the project
right so we want to be able to use this
to create you know even the project
folder and everything so now it's gonna
do its thing so create react app is now
installing obviously react web pack you
know all the dependencies that it needs
and there go done not bad under 30
seconds so you can see there's a lot of
stuff here so it's pretty awesome all
this stuff gets installed and it's ready
to go it's ready for us to write you can
see the instructions here not that hard
like right now if we type the orange
start we have an app so actually let's
do that I'm sorry whoops I got a seat
all right we got to go into our project
folder it's amazing how many times I do
that when I start a project like this I
forget to CD into the actual project
folder so let's type in yarn start and
this should start up so I have a lot of
other stuff running right now so it's
not gonna run on the default local hosts
I did not want it to run in that window
Olo if you can see right now it's it's
running right so we're using react so
it's that easy that I mean technically
we have reacts up and running it's
working it's just a default but I mean
that was pretty pretty fast alright so
let me go back back over to where we
were let's get this running
was that 3001 yeah okay all right so
obviously we're gonna remove a lot of
this stuff but let's find our there we
go so we want to I'm using I turn to and
I'm gonna duplicate the tab so I have
this other tab now since I'm running the
server on this tab I can't really do
anything there so I have another tab
that's in the same folder and now in
this tab this is where we're gonna run
everything so I think we'll probably
let's do a little bit before I actually
make this a git repo I really don't like
to make something to get repo right off
the back cuz some of the early steps to
set things up or just so basic I I don't
know for me it's just like white clutter
up my repo with some of that that stuff
alright so I do want to open up Adam so
I'm going to use Adam for this project
as my editor in it open on the wrong
screen so let me pull this over it's my
other screen I hope that my machine can
handle all this I just have so many
projects open right now let's see
there we go and make this fool screamed
for now all right so here's our project
you can see in our package.json we have
react 16 okay really basic right now
we're gonna pull in a lot of things we
have some basic you have set up things
that we do that we've been doing for all
of our projects on the stream so our
basic linting you Auto formatting with
prettier standard jazz we're definitely
going to bring that on we're gonna bring
in react router we're gonna bring in
Redux yeah so what you know why don't we
we bring in all that stuff now and we'll
set that stuff up before we even work at
all on on any of the UI so I actually
think I think I remember most of these
most cities commands so I don't think I
have to look up the documentation for
some of these since I've been using
using these and my my other side
projects lately so they should be able
to just do yarn add react router Dom
okay so if we're using it for the web
we won't react router Dom there's other
versions of react router for react
native so I'm gonna make sure we get the
right version and then also we want
redux actually I pretty sure it is Redux
but I do want to double check to make
sure that that is the correct thing so
we had I don't know like a month or so
ago there were NPM packages that were
named like slightly different than the
the normal package sisters posted on
load and actually had malicious code in
it so now I know I had double check
there we go
Redux on my other screen house trying to
look up Redux yep
it is Redux okay alright alright so this
is gonna install that alright awesome so
that was really fast that's confirmed
right we now have Redux
we have react router dawn great while
we're at it let's bring in prettier and
standard Jas right we don't really have
that much by way of code but we may as
well bring it in right off the bat and I
found before if I work on a project for
a while and then bring in standard Jas
and prettier and we in husky and we auto
format then I get a lot of errors and it
takes it's a lot harder to work through
that so if I bring it in right off the
bat then I make little changes and tests
so it's a lot easier to catch the errors
and work through them so and the code is
just cleaner right off the bat otherwise
it ends up being a mess after a while so
let's bring that in and for that I'm
just gonna go to let me find the project
where I'm already using it so this is
resource center okay so yep we're using
this in the resource center already
let's check out our package.json and we
will need this part of it so we're gonna
need I'm gonna copy as much of this as I
can
let's copy this this copy goodness
alright so we have a lot of stuff here
we're not gonna copy everything I should
say we're not gonna keep everything will
be our
we'll copy it and then take out what we
don't need just copy this for now and
put this down here so right now we don't
need I made all of these right we're
gonna leave State in there
we're gonna need that eventually so
we'll probably need these at some point
so I'm just gonna leave them in here
this is gonna make sure we don't get
errors from using these oops copied one
extra curly oops I forgot a comma
okay there we go I love syntax
highlighting helps to find errors so
quickly you know immediately I saw red
there and I knew like I never see red in
the package.json with with the color
scheme that I have so I just knew a use
never I just don't realize how much it
helps until I try to do something
without it and then it's just like just
so hard to look at code with without
highlighting okay so we have this you
don't need see we're not gonna run
and there's do we need node fetch
probably at some point we'll need it I'm
gonna take that nightmare for now we may
end up using this for testing at some
point but right now I'm gonna leave it
off probably need this okay we need okay
that looks good I'm not sure about all
of these that we need but that's close
enough we'll probably want to do as well
is update these so we'll do that too
now we don't have ships let's find a
project with
[Music]
that's let's look we have a lot more
going on here with our scripts but at
least we can find the lint and
pre-commit and
let's see that might be enough just to
get us started
so lint is gonna run all of this then we
commit I actually need to grab
actually may be good with that to start
test without watch we're not gonna run
I'm not gonna run the test because we
didn't bring that in yet so okay that
should be good enough there may be some
other stuff in here that we'll want to
bring out bring in after a while but
this is quite enough right now all right
so I'm gonna save that and then we're
gonna run yarn and that's going to
install whoa I got an error unexpected
token so have something in here that
should not be here
mm-hmm
I think it's that one you can't have a
trailing comma yep that was it
so that'll run if you didn't catch that
I've had this happen to me several times
the last item in an array or in an
object can't have a comma or else you
get an error okay cool
so that looks like it works but what I
also want to do since it's possible that
some of these packages have received
upgrades since we started the last
project I just want to upgrade them
right now before we get too involved it
should be easier to find any any issues
with them before we have other things
going on so I think it's a yarn upgrade
it's either yarn upgrade or yarn updates
all of your dependencies are up-to-date
okay cool
I'm actually really surprised by that is
that the right way okay that's not it
that must be it must be the command I
just really thought that there would
have been some newer versions of these
okay it's possible that I did update
that project recently and I just don't
remember okay so let's see what we have
all right we have we do have some
JavaScript files in here already that we
can try to run the lint on and see if it
changes anything so to run lint
URL is not defined in this Service
Worker all right so let's add that so
this is why we have this down here this
global so you can pull this out into a
separate file which I've done some times
but our package JSON is really not that
big so I don't mind putting it in here
for now if it got huge I would
definitely pull it out though okay
all right great so it ran through it see
if it moved anything around I don't
really remember what that looked like
well enough to know if it moved anything
around but we'll see an action later on
as we as we do more okay so that's the
end of the first Pomodoro session we
have react we're an create react apps we
have react installed with all the cool
stuff that comes along with create react
app we have installed Redux and react
router we have Auto formatting and
linting of our code with prettier
standard j/s husky so every time we go
to commit right we have this pre-commit
hook now that will run our linter so it
will run lint stage down here in lint
stays on any javascript file it will run
prettier
right we have some some parameters here
some flags here for what we want no
semicolons we want single quotes and
this will actually fix it it's not just
gonna get less warnings it'll it'll
change our code which is awesome so
we'll have a standard style even if you
you know get once we make this a get
repo if you were to clone this and
commit it would all be formatted the
same and and then we'll do a git add so
let me make sure components all right
this should all work all right awesome
so let's do our five-minute
question-and-answer session and then
we'll come back in we do a little bit
more and we'll make this a we'll put
this on github
before we end as well and then that way
if you want to review it or if you want
to just kind of copy it when it's at
this early stage and use it as like a
boilerplate that would that would work
too okay
well I have quite a lot in the live chat
already well we have a we have a lot of
viewers so awesome so imagine there's
probably some new viewers welcome I'm
going five minutes a question and answer
now but if I don't get to your question
don't worry about it I'll get to them
later on so at the end whatever I
haven't got to I'll go through at all
and I'll answer all the questions so if
you have a question to stick around and
I will get to it okay so right now I'm
just scanning through the live chat
looking for any questions
okay so also some helpful comments I'll
read out as well I see a lot of you
you're saying hi and what's up so hey
everyone so James says I believe that
single sign-on is going to be the best
bet
I agree I agree I'm hoping that I'm
gonna have a meeting about it on Friday
and I'm gonna ask more about the
possibility of linking up the bulletin
to the single sign-on system I hope that
goes through I want to get out of the
business of handling login issues
because I've gotten quite a few calls
and emails about this and it just takes
up a lot of my time so I think the IT
department is more well suited to handle
that they have a help desk and a
ticketing system and you know actual
like employees whose job it is to take
calls like that and so that's not really
what my job is although I've been doing
that because I I want my stuff to work
and I'm upset when it doesn't work but
yeah definitely
definitely think the single sign-on will
be the best way to go
let's see Fernando says are you using
JSON P what do you use to fetch JSON P
data now it's just it's regular JSON
it's not JSON P so I use fetch so
currently in the current jQuery version
of this it's all client-side so
client-side fetch in this version that
we're gonna make with react I'd like to
do everything server-side or at least I
should say this I don't know that I need
to do everything server-side potentially
we could do some calls client-side I
don't need this to be rendered
server-side at all so we'll see how it
goes
I see dentist that said you just
installed it again to update so awesome
thanks I didn't look up to see you so
that but that was definitely the what I
was what I was wondering about Kevin
says in response to the JMP question is
that Jason fees will work around four
cores so the cross origin request if you
use your own API or one with cores
header like the WordPress API then you
don't need to worry about JSON T yeah
that's that's spot-on right there yeah
so since we have we are going to use the
WordPress API we don't have to worry
about that let's see okay Kevin also
said Jesse will probably use native
fetch with the polyfill fallback yep
exactly
Harshit says try using password list npm
module for password this authentication
okay cool I'll have to check that out I
was I have been checking out some
different options right now I'm using
auth0
to handle the password this stuff but I
think I do want to switch to something
else I mean all 0 is nice
but the plan there their level of their
plan right now I'm using the free
version of of--there because there's not
that many users but to get integration
with the single sign-on I'd have to jump
up to their business plan and it's just
not worth it for that much money every
month for an internal bulletin so I
think you know we're going to try to go
with something else let's see
all right so I'm gonna mark down where I
left off at the live chat okay so I did
look up on my other screen the password
list NPM package so I'm going to leave
that on my screen so I don't forget and
check that out after the stream so
thanks for that
Harshit and okay so let's get back to
coding
I just never the less comment I just
noticed was just joined and while
insurance in the US isn't that case so
yeah I don't really know how it's like
what it's like in other countries but
here
yeah insurance is weird in terms of
which where you can go basically you're
kind of limited so depending on what
surance you have insurance you have you
may not be able to go to a certain
doctor that you want to go to or
hospital and I mean you could always go
there and just pay on your own but
that's a lot of money so yeah but I mean
the good news is I will go to see the
doctor that I want to go see I just have
to wait a little bit longer so and it's
not I mean I'm not gonna be in serious
trouble by waiting another month
I've already been waiting I've already
been dealing with this for several
months not that big of a deal okay so
the next step so yeah this will running
what's our next step oh let's let's hook
up Redux into our app and also react
router right we don't really have
anything set up for routes but let's
just get this all hooked up now
and so we're gonna want to go to our app
I'm actually gonna bring up I'm gonna
bring up on my other screen and oh I'm
going to github right now and I'm gonna
check out that last Redux project that I
did on github that I showed everyone was
it this I guess last week I showed
everyone and that is the Udacity react
and the readable projects said it yeah
okay so if you if you want to check out
where I'm getting the code from since I
just implemented Redux with react router
um I'm not going to try to go through
documentation again I'm just gonna look
at what I did and so this is it and this
will be probably the last project that I
worked on from my own github account so
let's check out our source folder and I
think it's an abscess yep this is it
alright so I'm gonna move this over so I
can copy and paste more easily but like
I said you can check that out if you
want okay so in our app dot J s that's
in our source folder and I'll make this
a little bigger for you all
so in our source folder we are going to
bring in a bunch of stuff so I'm gonna
copy and paste a bunch and then I'll go
through about what all these things are
and we'll end up taking out some stuff
eventually like you know logo dot SVG
things like that
but for right now it's fun to keep it in
so here's what we brought in browsing
router route and switch from reactor
outer dome okay may or may not use all
these we can remove the stuff we don't
need
we're gonna import create store apply
middleware and compose from redux all
right obviously and if you've done this
before this is kind of basic but for
those of you who are new to react it
might be helpful if I kind of go through
these we're importing now right now we
don't have reducers right so we're gonna
have to make that but we're gonna want
to bring that in and we're gonna import
provider from react redux and [ __ ] are
we gonna actually I don't know if when
you dunk or not you think yeah we might
end up needing so I should bring that in
so probably what I'll need to do is is
pull these in so I don't get errors so
let me check the package.json for this
project see what else I need what I
forgot to bring in and I did I forgot to
bring in a few packages so let's do that
right now so the yarn and we need react
redux
and redux thunk
there we go okay
make sure didn't miss anything else
okay
so now those will load well yeah we'll
let that do its thing yep coming in so
let's go back over here and continue to
add these and and right now normally we
would import our views so I'm just gonna
put some of this here so we don't forget
to import our views and just see what we
would what we do here so you don't have
to do this in your app dutchess if you
don't have that many views I think it's
fine but otherwise you could have like a
routes component where you put all your
routes in so we may move it into another
component at some point but for now it's
it's easier to see it all at once like
this so we would bring in for each like
page or each you we wanted we would
import it so we've imported that
component for now we don't have any of
these created so I'm gonna comment all
of them out and then let's bring in
this alright so we're gonna use this
logger okay so we want okay we want more
than just the basic redux right we want
to bring in some tools to help us figure
out what's going on with our store so
that's where is this some of this comes
in so this is optional but very helpful
I don't I wouldn't really want to work
with redux without some of these tools
to help I'm pretty new with redux maybe
you know if someone's more advanced with
it they wouldn't need it but I
definitely need some of this stuff so
this this logger we're gonna get a bunch
of stuff in our console also let's bring
in let's let me bring in a few things
here okay so this is going to be our dev
tools extension and I think I showed you
all that extension last week and we'll
definitely see it again as we work on
this project but this is very helpful
it's gonna add another another tab onto
our dev tools window and we're gonna be
able to see a lot of information about
our store right so while this is
definitely useful this is more user
friendly so probably not necessary to
have both maybe one or the other I think
especially in development more
information is better but I could
definitely see especially with this your
console can get quite cluttered so may
not be a bad idea to get rid of this if
you're trying to hunt out like other
errors and it's just too cluttered but
definitely keep this one okay and then
here we're actually creating our store
now here's the thing we are not bringing
in that reducer yet so we're gonna at
least need to create the file and I'm
not sure if it'll be enough just to
create the file or if we'll still get
errors but I mean we're definitely gonna
get in an error
nothing there at all and then this is
where we pull in our middleware so we're
bringing in right
our logger thunk our Redux dev tools
right so ringing thunk from here bring
in our logger from here ok let's go down
a little bit further so we need to wrap
everything in provider so that way our
application has access to the store
right so now everything is wrapped in
that now since we're also using react
router we're gonna wrap everything in
browser router as well
okay so right now we don't have routes
but potentially we could have a setup
something like this where inside of here
we don't actually have you know whereas
right now we have markup for our
homepage we would get rid of all the
markup there and inside of this would
just be our browser router and then
switch in and all arouse you can see our
home page becomes a component our home
component right and here's our other
views so we'll probably end up building
something like this for now it's not
necessary we'll have to take a look and
just think about all the different
routes that we want and then we'll set
those up okay so I'm just gonna look
through here quickly just to make sure I
haven't missed anything oh we need to
make our our reducers right so let's do
that now or at least make our reducer
folder so we're just gonna make on a
command line we're gonna make directory
so mkdir to make directory I haven't
done this on Windows for a while is it
the same on Windows I'm on a Mac right
now it's the same one Linux I know there
are some differences in command line
commands on Windows but having done most
development on Windows so it's actually
been at least two years now so don't
remember all the differences so anyway
our gonna make directory we're gonna
call it reducers oops we want it to be
in our source folder and then and then
reducers okay now we're also going to
make a file so we're gonna do touch is
how you make a file we're going to
source reducers and then we want to call
this index
oops index dot J us not a CMO okay so
now we should be able to see reducers
index all right so let's save that see
if we get any errors yep we got an error
what's going on here expected the
reducer to the function okay so I'm not
I do need to do a little bit more than I
have done with the reducers so let's see
what's this what's the least I can do
and every reducer
let's see
let's see dishes
so I'm look at my other screams Jennifer
yeah what's the minimum I could write in
my reducer at this point
oh let's just do this let's find a
producer and let's see if we can get
away with doing okay so at first we
definitely want to export when we're
gonna want to bring in combined reducers
some of us will just do it right now
okay so we're bringing that in so we can
have more than one reducer we don't have
any actions set up right now so normally
you would import your actions as well
but I don't have that set up this is the
thing about Redux that's was frustrating
to me when I first did it is that it
doesn't really work unless you have
reducers your store your actions all in
place so we'll see I'm not even sure if
this will work unless I put in some
actions but let's see basically we're
definitely going to need posts so let's
see if we can get posed let me make sure
I didn't miss something up here okay a
function and we want this to be say
she posts uh name at that for now we
could always change it we're gonna make
this state
so just by default we'll have just an
empty object for the state and then you
know what I think I am gonna have to
pull in the action we'll see we might
not so anyway here's our action so we'll
pull in here is our state as a default
so this is a default parameter so if
there is no state passed in it will
default to this otherwise it will take
whatever state we pass in and then
inside of here we want a switch
statement and we want action type okay
so if you haven't worked with Redux
before this probably doesn't make very
much sense but what we're gonna have is
another file called actions we're going
to import that into there based on what
the type of action is we're gonna want
to do something different in this
function so that's what we're that's
we're pulling in so if let's say if the
case is I don't know get posts and I'm
open to suggestions for naming because
I'm just trying to name what whatever I
can hear based on what I think we'll
need we don't need this break so if the
case is get posts let's return and we're
gonna run a return state and then we're
gonna run to turn this house
those see
see how I'm not really sure what I'm
naming everything right now so we'll
just put that in there for now I think
that should work
we'll see we'll get an error if it
doesn't and then we're just going to
return state by default so for right now
we shouldn't get anything because we're
not actually passing in anything so it
should just return nothing for the state
and then down here actually since we're
combining reducers let's do this and
we're gonna do is I am gonna want to
have sorting maybe a sort function or
filter
let's have some sort of sorting and for
now I'm just gonna leave that sorting
okay that'll probably make sense later
but I want to keep basically information
about how we're gonna sort the the posts
I'm gonna keep that in our store and
then that way it can persist across
across components across use more easily
okay now let's export for defaults
combined so this is where that combined
reducers comes in combined reducers and
[Music]
now we can put together our receive
posts and our sorting
okay
let's save that and see what kind of
errors we get get post or not to find so
sorting okay let's define those then we
I think we are gonna have to make our
actions as well but that's not a big
deal we may as well set the whole thing
up now and it'll be kind of a more
complete explanation of everything
so let's import when we say get post and
[Music]
what else do we wanna get those and set
sorting from we're going to say actions
okay so yeah right so we don't have
actions so now let's make a folder
called actions so let's go back here
actions and also I'm going to make file
our actions and
[Music]
now let's make some actions and let's
put it over here put them side-by-side
so we can remember what's going on here
okay so we're going to eventually we may
have some API calls happening for now
I'm not gonna worry about that but what
we do want to do is export so we want to
exports okay and so now we're going to
use these constants instead of the
strings down here also obviously here
right so let's go
so this is going to be good Oh schools
oh s--- and in here we're gonna make an
object and we're gonna send out it so
this is where the type comes in so you
can see over here we want to get action
type here's the type so this is where we
want to put get posts all right so
that'll let this reduce or know what we
want to do and then we're gonna pass in
our posts okay and we want to do the
same thing for a sorting
so sorter that we called it was it
sorting set sorting set sorting and
let's go sort by and sort okay let's see
I caught it sorter huh let's just
changes here loser okay so you can see
in both cases what's gonna get sent from
here now this is not everything right we
actually I wonder if I can make it work
just like that normally I would do more
it might actually work let's just see if
this works enough to get this to load
awesome so it actually did load so now
at least I can show you in dev tools a
Redux panel okay so obviously our state
right so we have two parts to our state
we have that received posts and we have
sorting right and that corresponds to
what we've done here receive posts and
sorting right now they're just empty
arrays or I'm sorry empty objects if
I've been saying arrays that was on
accident these are objects apologize for
that right so right now that's the end
of a 25-minute session so I'm gonna do
five minutes of questions but just to
summarize we've got Redux connected here
at the root of our our app here we have
Redux connected we've added some
middleware so we have some console
logging going on with our store we have
our extension for depth
and we have thunk which we aren't using
yet but we probably will use later on we
also brought in react router although we
haven't done anything with routes yet
it's all ready to do we've set up our
reducers and we set up some actions ok
now we're not entirely finished with our
actions but it's set up enough so that
we don't get errors and we're able to
see our state so not bad we've come a
long way and in our two 25-minute
Pomodoro sessions so let me start my
five-minute timer and I'm gonna go to
the live chat and answer some more
questions all right so I'm pretty behind
on the questions thanks for your
patience if you're waiting for me to
answer your question
okay Harsha said if you are using yarn
for everything try using yarn Global for
global packages actually I should do
that I don't know why I used NPM and
didn't think about using yarn globally
anyway see John Hansen says yarn start
is the easy part
yes yeah this is all kind of the easy
part for right now okay Harshit sis
saying you forgot react Redux so thanks
for that I didn't see that beforehand
eventually I did figure it out though
but thank you for for putting that in
the left shot for me Ishmael says how
can I get what he's copying I don't have
the project actually here let me put
this on the screen again because this
was a different project so let's let me
let me copy I'm gonna put this link in
the live chat right now and maybe I'll
put it it I'm gonna try my best to
remember afterwards to put it in the
description so that the link I just
paste it in is where I was copying a lot
of this from this is a redux project
that I did for my Udacity nano degree I
just finished it up last week actually I
did I just finished it up over the
weekend I think so Saturday I finished
it sorry if there is just a noise my mic
fell over so hopefully it's alright now
okay Kevin asks if I've used atoms get
integration no I haven't used it yet
I'll have to try it out this so if
anybody does use atoms get integration
what do you think about it is it is it
better than using you know a separate
like terminal to handle all your get
stuff I wonder so you get how
interesting you can create a repo right
from here cool
I'll have to play around with that later
on
Patrick caught that trailing comma
before I did too so thanks Patrick good
eye on that one
let's see Blake asked how long does it
take to run create react app I think
what it took almost 30 seconds to do it
I'm sure it depends on your computer but
it was pretty pretty fast
oh okay thank you so harsh it says use
yarn upgrade with a flag latest so I'm
gonna do that now
it's always interesting when this
happens to see if anything breaks we try
to use latest but at the beginning of
the project is definitely the time to do
something like that so it looks like
only one what wood has been updated is
in Craig food it looks like a lot of
warnings and so I guess a lot did not
need to be updated
hmm
okay
bread says I typically just watched
Jesse's live streams and don't try to
follow along maybe make some notes on
paper when I do create the project I
watch the video and pause if I get stuck
ok cool I actually like hearing how how
people watch these I know some people
have said that they go back and like
they watched the recording on like 2
times speed somebody even said they
watched it on four times speed before
and then I know some of you work on
other projects and just kind of listen
in the background and joining the live
chat you know if you hear something that
you know you're interested in so that's
kind of cool
I mean I know these it's not like the
normal coding tutorial video or anything
like that so I think it's cool that
there's different ways to handle this
live stream alright so my 5 minutes is
up and let's see ok so I marked down
where I stopped in the live chat and now
let's do we've done two Pomodoro
sessions which that's usually the
minimum I think I'm going to do one more
Pomodoro session and in this session we
would definitely commit this would make
it a repo we'll commit it put it on
github that way you all will have access
to all of this and then we'll see so
probably what I'm gonna start with is
making it a repo actually let's just to
continue with what we were doing let's
finish off this actions file here this
is we need a little bit more before
it'll really be functional then we'll
commit everything if we have extra time
after that then we'll move on and see
what else we can do ok
so what we want to do you find
trying to find my other projects the
simplest example for now most of my
actions involve making a call to an API
rather find a better example
maybe I
actually maybe this is fine let me let
me pull over what I've been doing so
I've been doing things like this so oh
yeah so I've been doing things like this
where I wouldn't directly call this I
would call like let's imagine this is
fetch post into the category so I would
call fetch post then it would from from
another file which would be this API
utility then it would pull in from the
API the posts then it would call let's
say get posts and pass that in but I
guess since I'm not doing that right now
this should work and in this case
directly from a component I would just
dispatch this action and then pass in
whatever I want so for now I think we'll
be fine
but just know that if we wanted to call
an API where we would do it is probably
in here I would put all the API stuff in
another file and then from the component
we would call the action that would then
make the API call and then what gets
returned from that call would get passed
to another action this action would only
be called from inside of the actions
folder anyway and then that data would
get passed to the reducer and then the
reducer is what takes that information
and basically let's see where deucer is
so the reducer would then take that
information and do whatever we tell it
to do with that in this case it's it's
combining it with the previous state so
what we wanted to do is only update the
things that have changed okay and then
that gets
that's what ends up getting into the
store and then it becomes available to
our components to use so that's kind of
the flow I am NOT an expert in Redux
I've developed one thing that has
successfully worked with Redux so just
keep that in mind whenever going through
my explanation of redux this is a way to
do Redux that has worked for me one time
so I don't want to give you the wrong
impression that this is the way to do it
but it is a way that does work probably
not the best way but I don't really know
okay so now having realized that this is
sufficient for now let's just turn this
into a git repo so let's run git move
this up a bit I just now I realized that
my timer I never started it and also
it's being blocked by my face so now you
can see it nothing that matters for to
give you an idea how much time we have
left so let's get in it get in it okay
so we've initialized this and let's go
with so now we can see this is what we
have that would be being our git
repository so we'll see so when we do
create react app it already came with
the get ignore file so we don't have to
worry about that now if you were doing a
project and you weren't really strapping
it with anything you would want to have
your own gate ignore file or maybe you
have a global file but anyway so all
this stuff doesn't get included right so
that's why our node modules aren't
included when we get we did status so
we're gonna do a git add write kit add
also we need to put the dot for all now
let's check the status again right so
everything now is
and is ready to be committed so now
we'll do a git commit I'm gonna use the
EM flag right to burn a commit message
right there in line and I'm just gonna
say an it for initial our initial commit
right now if we check our status we're
all good right nothing needs to be
committed but we're not actually linked
up with github yet right there's nothing
on there so that's our next step let's
go to github and let me bring this over
so here we have github and let's make a
new repo I want
FUS mark on so that's Franciscan
University still the marketing
communications department where I work
and we're gonna call this bulletin react
okay it's just a little description we
are gonna make this public and yeah we
have a readme so we're not gonna
initialize with the readme doing how to
license let's add a license and we'll
just go with this that should be fine
I'm not really super knowledgeable about
the difference in licenses I usually
look them up every time but I'm pretty
sure that this will be okay for what
we're doing and we we don't want to add
get ignored we already have one so let's
create this okay so now let's
wait a second
sorry usually I'm losing my mind here I
could have sworn that usually another
screen pops up initially that has some
other some other options did I mess this
up let me check the live chat see if I
messed it up maybe I hit the wrong thing
no nobody said I hit the wrong thing I
need to pull in an existing repository
is that enough it's possible that I just
messed this up hola
oh okay so thank you Jake Jake said it's
because I added the license
so the first commit was the license okay
what's gonna be faster it may be faster
to just delete this and do it again
because now I have let's just delete it
and do it again honestly supposed to
already exists yeah I didn't want to hit
back
I just wanted to delete all right okay
see there's there's some commands I can
just came out at origin all right I
won't delete it let's just work with
this all right so let's go get remote
okay I think this is it
okay
all right so
great there's no tracking information
set upstream
should be
okay
using to merge unrelated histories so
it's just push them get close
nope dang it
is there some way you can force okay
no refusing diversion really issues
again alright let me check the latch out
again
maybe I should just delete the license
and then the fish organized yeah so I I
tried to do a git push origin master
already and I'm getting maybe doing a
pool rebase let's let's just see okay
awesome okay so thank you thank you Matt
I got the flag now where's my there it
is okay
yes
it's
this is whoa all right
so it popped up on my other screen to
have me put in a merge message there we
go
okay cool
all right now let's check it make sure
it went through everything works looks
like it works okay great so yeah it was
actually kind of cool that that happened
I've never had that happen to me before
but it's good to know so if you're
trying to initialize a new repository
probably better just to not add the
license that readme get ignore with
github because then you're gonna have to
merge like we did here so this is what
ended up working so thanks again Matt
for that get pool with a flag allow
unrelated histories ok so there might
have been other ways to do it probably
usually with get there's definitely like
more than one way to do a thing but
that's what works but we ended up with
two different initial commits so a
little bit sloppy here at the beginning
that's okay but now we have it so now
basically everything that we've just
done is available in github if I hadn't
have added this license what would have
happened is that it would have taken me
to a screen that would have had I think
like three different sets of
instructions depending on what I wanted
to do one of those sets I believe it's
the middle one would have had
instructions for how to bring in the
repository that I had locally into into
here so would have just had me add you
know like the remote so pretty much the
same steps only when we did the push it
would have just worked we wouldn't have
to have done the pool merge and then
push okay
and CEO Samuel okay that's for 13
minutes let's see let me just take a
quick look at where we're at with this
project to see if it's worth it to
finish out this Pomodoro session or just
wait for the next session so we have our
linting
we could probably set up a few routes
for our views I just saw on the live
chat Jimmy says does he reply to his
viewers yes I do reply to the viewers
but I go back and forth between coding
and replying so after I finish up this
session of coding I'm gonna reply to
everything so just hang in there for a
little while longer if you can
and I'll answer any questions that you
have okay so yeah let's go through and
just add a few routes that we know that
we need so let's get rid of this logo I
don't need that anymore we're going to
take it out and let me take all of this
out we're gonna add in a switch
nope not that kind of switch
and then we're gonna add in some routes
and I think I have some routes that I
can copy and paste
yeah let's copy and paste a few routes
in here just to save us some time so
obviously we're gonna want a home route
so let's just we'll stick with that
we'll make a component called home and
then we're going to uncomment that and
then let's see what else do we want we
don't need to create post actually I
think these two can stay what else what
else would we have
yeah let's just stick with these three
for now we may want to add some more I'm
gonna have to give this some more
thought kind of look look over what we
have now and just see what the best way
would be to set these up but these three
I know for sure we'll need so we have
these now when I save this I'm gonna get
an error because these files don't
actually exist yet get rid of this one
and uncomment these so we need to make a
folder called views and then we need to
add these these files so let's go back
to our command line and see we obviously
we have the error let me get rid of some
of this as well okay
so skill I think directory use source
views let's actually want to go into it
it'll just be easier to make multiple
files so we want to make a home is hey
let's see we want when we want
category dot J s and post detail Dodge
ass okay so that should have just made
all three of those and we'll check it
out
yep so now we have all three of these I
yeah so that does not not actually done
anything because we don't have anything
in those files you get so let's let's
just make something in these files so we
can get rid of yours so that's what
would be the quickest thing we could do
let me see if I can just copy and paste
some you know boilerplate stuff in here
hmm
a lot of stuff that I'm saying is is way
more advanced than boilerplate let's see
if I can find something really simple
so I can't find anything really simple
right now I'm just gonna have to copy
and paste something a little bit more
complex and then get rid of a lot but
it's actually not bad because we can see
how we hook up some of these things from
redux so let me just go over this for
now so up at the top we've imported
connect and we're putting in so we have
our map state two props this is going to
make the state whatever we want from our
store available as props in this
component so in this case we have our
categories available we also are
bringing in our dispatch so if you
remember in our actions this is how we
can pull in and call those those actions
right so for one thing we now have
dispatch available to use but we can
also use fetch we use Fest data within
our component and that calls this that
dispatches this fetch categories and we
could pass in things if we need it to
here and then so we're not just normally
exporting our component which in this
case I just copy side nav from another
project but we're using connect first
and then we have the side nav of there
which there's a name for this it's
called currying so when you when you do
it like this it's called currying I'm
not gonna attempt to explain currying
because it's a new concept for me that I
just learned within the last month but
that's what it's called if you want to
look it up and figure out more about
what's going on here so for now I'm
gonna get rid of this because we don't
you'll need it see if I can
shouldn't see if I could leave something
in here and it wouldn't mess anything up
I guess state we could pull in something
so let's pull something in here we have
get posts yeah so let's pull in posts I
know there's nothing right now but since
we're going to have this stuff at some
point we may as well just bring it in so
state ok and for a dispatch let's just
get rid of this for now
whoops get rid of the wrong one
you'll probably end up pulling that map
dispatch the props back in at some point
when we set up our API calls but for now
we don't have those set up so I don't
want to include them let's get rid of a
lot of this stuff so pretty much
everything let's just keep actually
let's do something cool
that's react 16 let's put in let me
remember the syntax for this
I think it's we're gonna return an array
so let's return an array let's do h1 key
one and then
to CP
okay we are gonna have to rename this
and also we don't need this
and let's pull out meat connects though
but so this is where we would bring in
import some of our actions that we
wanted to use that we wanted to dispatch
so for now we're not gonna use any of
those but I guess we could just comment
it out since we will be pulling some in
when we're not gonna use link right now
but we probably will end up having some
links probably in we'll probably have a
separate side knife component at some
point so may not use the link here
because each post love its own component
but import status I don't think we have
that yeah we don't have styles yet so
we'll comment it out but we will have
styles we may end up doing some styling
a different way we may do our Styles try
to do everything inside the component
we'll see I like to try out different
things styling wise especially with
react because there's so many different
ways of doing styling but we'll see will
this work maybe this should work for
this one and we can just copy and paste
this for all our other views that was
category of you know all right let me
change this
category all right let's save that now
let's go to the home view and put that
in there great okay save that and then
finally post let's call this
alright now let's see if this works no I
must use the wrong syntax
alright I'm gonna have to look up the
syntax then I thought I had it yeah I do
that all the way already up on a screen
alright so let me bring this over she
could see what I'm talking about so this
is a is react version 16 it goes through
some of the new stuff and first thing on
here is okay so you returned it like
that that's what I was going for
initially let's see this will work now
and my timer just went up so this will
be the last thing that we do so if it
works
did it not work what am I doing wrong
I should be able to return that
is it only for for elements that are
alike oh do I need to put maybe I need
to do this because it's an array right
that makes sense see if this works now
it's not showing it
oh well I guess I'm doing it wrong I
didn't read it wrong it's possible yeah
it's possible that maybe you can't do
elements that aren't alike
hmm yeah the only example on here does
show all the elements to the same
elements so maybe that's maybe that's
the issue so actually let's know I don't
I don't see why that would be an issue
okay I could just I got it I got to
figure this out I'm like this will be
the last thing that we do let's see
all right so I would like to know before
we end this dream what what the issue is
with this and why it's not working if
I'm misunderstanding this
all right let's see
by this asagi love this other component
so maybe I am misunderstanding how this
is supposed to work
alright I'm gonna try one more thing see
if it works and then if it doesn't work
I'm just gonna wrap these in another
element and so I'm gonna try to make
these both paragraph tags that was
and see those
and just
let me fix this page so it looks like
this
I think the error I'm getting is
unrelated to this so it looks like maybe
that this would actually work as long as
you're using the same the same tags so
now what is going on here
okay so the root component is wrapped in
provider so that should work so what's
going on here Connect
let's check out
see art we're bringing in provider we
have wrap this in provider and then this
is inside of that okay that's weird
all right let me
it's preferring this tourism
ok so I got something going on with
oh you're okay Harshit you're right I'd
never passed the store so okay thank you
for catching that okay awesome okay so
home this is the home page let's go to
category
this is category page awesome and if we
do category slash whatever it should
give us the post detail page great okay
so this works we already saw that our
store was working now we were actually
are passing the store down react router
is working we have our routes and we've
done some cool react 16 stuff and that
we've returned to elements without them
being in a containing element so pretty
cool so so far we've we use one of the
new react 16 cool things that it can do
alright so I definitely went over my 25
minute session there so I'm going to go
to the live chat now it's been a long
stream already so I totally understand
if you can't stick around for the live
chat if that's the case then thank you
so much for watching and join us again
sometime please but if you can stick
around even if you don't have a question
it would be awesome if you could stick
around and help to add your expertise to
our answers to the questions if you do
have a question go and put it in the
live chat now I'm gonna do my best to
get to all the questions and if I have
an answer I will give an answer and a
lot of the other people in the live chat
are very knowledgeable and can
can add to the answers okay so I'm going
to scroll back up to where I left off
and just go down through the list
ahman says Redux versus mob x your views
so I have not used mob X yet
I have watched some YouTube videos on
mob X and seen a presentation at a
conference on mob X based on that it
seems like mob X is easier to use but as
I said I haven't used it yet i've only
used redux so i don't know for sure you
know from personal experience I'm also
I'm not 100% sure which situations would
be better in terms of you know it is is
mob X a perfect replacement for redux
you know could it be used in every
situation I don't know so I don't have
enough experience with it so at this
point I'm using redux because I've
learned Redux that's what I know I'm
definitely open to using mob X in the
future but I would like to get a little
bit better with redux first so that I
could make a more informed you know
comparison when I switch and try out my
bags rohan asked what single sign-on
provider will you guys be using actually
I don't I don't know what they're going
with right now so I'll have an answer
for you later on so they said on Friday
I'm gonna have a meeting the meeting is
actually related to how we're gonna
brand the single sign-on there's going
to be some discussion about rebranding
some of the applications that the
university uses so maybe like a
different look different naming I'm in
favor of just being really simple and
straightforward with the naming so we'll
see how that meeting goes but I am gonna
bring up tying in this project into the
single sign-on system so I don't know if
there'll be anybody at the meeting
that's directly working on the technical
side of this but at least I'll be able
to figure out who I should talk to
that's that can give me the answers
about you know technically how are we
gonna tie this in so maybe for Friday's
stream I'll have an answer okay so James
Henderson says it is a pain let me know
if you have any questions on the single
sign-on oh I definitely I appreciate you
offering offering the help so yeah I
mean I guess it it has to be somewhat
complicated they've been working on it
for a while so must not be the easiest
of things to do
q the dev says what level of coding is
this I'm fairly new to coding should I
stay or view your earlier videos did get
some answers to that already
Blake Thomas says I'm a beginner but
this is still neat to listen and to pick
up a few things Brett says I'd stay on
but if you go back to Jesse's first
react project using next jsut be in good
shape that one is simpler to start with
yeah yeah basically I would agree with
that assessment so occasionally we do
things that are more simple more
beginner friendly usually when we do
some of the like just building out the
UI using CSS and things that's somewhat
more beginner friendly but sometimes we
do get into some back-end things DevOps
and so those are more advanced but I do
I think that there are some things some
useful things I try my best to explain
things as I go through so I think even a
beginner could get some useful things
out of this if you can make it through
all the other parts also the question
and answer session is always open to
anything so if you do have a question
about something you know you need a
little bit more explanation or you have
a question that's just entirely
unrelated to that project we're working
on that's fine too so then you can still
get something out of the livestreams but
certainly understand if you know maybe
at this point you're not getting
out of it you know totally
understandable but definitely ask
questions if you can I'm open to that
okay kevin says Jesse just a reminder to
check the last few comments whenever
there is a bug thanks thanks for that
Kevin I you would think that I would
remember automatically from now on but
sometimes I remember sometimes I don't
so I'm sure I'll get better at that as I
as I scream more okay harsh it says
Redux saga is also great for async calls
and Redux instead of Redux thunks okay I
have I haven't used saga yet but I have
heard about it so maybe I'll maybe I'll
try that out we'll see I mean we haven't
really done anything yet with thunks so
it's possible that we could just switch
over to saga at some point so let me
know what you all think which one do you
think is easier to implement is one
clearly better than the other one
so at this point you know we're just
starting out so now's the time to to
switch if I'm going to switch I'll
definitely have to do a little bit of
learning to figure out how to do it but
yeah if one's clearly better then let me
know I'll definitely switch to be asked
what is a thunk okay so probably be good
to look up Redux thunks because I don't
know that my explanation is gonna be the
best but Redux thunks are good when
you're doing things like API calls
basically the handle try trying to
remember how this was explained
initially to me I've used them and I
know they're helpful but how do I
explain it if anybody has to get
explanation please put it in I don't see
anything right now but basically let me
see it's a it's a way to handle
asynchronous things in Redux so someone
please correct me if I'm if I'm the
this handle in this room but I think the
best way it's a way to handle things
that would be asynchronous with in redux
like trying to think I should just I
should look up you know quickly what the
correct terminology is I don't want to
lead anyone astray here
okay
so here's the official explanation this
may or may not help for those of you who
can't see the screen right now I will
read it out Redux thunk middleware
allows you to write action creators that
return a function instead of an action
the thunk can be used to delay the
dispatch of an action or to dispatch
only if certain conditions are met the
inner function receives the store
methods dispatch and get state as
parameters an action creator that
returns a function to perform an
asynchronous dispatch okay so here's
some code example to do the asynchronous
dispatch here's one to do the
conditional dispatch okay so I think in
my case how we'd be using thunks is more
like we're gonna return basically the
idea that we can return a function
instead of an action is what's useful to
to my case so you can check out as well
the repo was that yeah so this is the
repo that I was using before to to get
some examples when I was copy and
pasting things so we can see reserve
reducers actions okay so here's what I'm
doing with some of the actions then like
I'm using let's see where I'm pulling
this init
yes you've seen some of my dispatches
and let me actually show you the API as
well I'm kind of flying through this I
know but you can look at this more
slowly if you want to if you go to my
github profile that's or misc is opposed
you to okay so here's how I'm calling
these and then I'm returning the data in
JSON format so plays it obviously I'm
not like completely an expert on thunks
I just know how to use them and I know
that they they work but I can't give a
great explanation for it but anyway it
looks like there's an in-depth
introduction to thunks here so I'm not
gonna go through it but here's what it
is what it looks like so yeah that's
that's pretty long that might be one of
the longest Stack Overflow answers I've
ever seen
so anyway I guess check check out the
github repo for for Redux thunk sorry I
couldn't give you a great explanation
but hopefully I gave you some resources
they can explain it better than I can
okay cool earlier I was mentioning that
Windows command line commands are are
different so in the case I was talking
about the make directory so mkdir for
Linux and Mac makes a new directory in
windows it's MD so but har should also
said you can get the bash commands for
Windows pretty easily and you can run
Linux subsystem for Windows as well so
that's really cool
if I start developing on Windows again
I'm definitely enough to set that up oh
cool har should also typed in the bare
minimum function that I needed when I
was looking for to set up the reducers
so thanks horseshit I'm sorry I didn't
look over at that that would have been
faster but it's not too bad we have some
you know basic stuff set up that I know
we'll use later on so I guess it worked
out
is Slee ninja says why switch if if can
do the same job
Harshit responded saying it is the
common practice in the read up community
do you switch to handle action type so
also says I feel it's more readable
personally so yeah basically I mean
that's how I learned to do it I've never
seen it done otherwise it doesn't seem
like it's very useful right now since we
only have one case but usually I have a
lot more cases than that so you can see
I think one of these is my yeah so you
can see all right select for this one
I'm like 7 cases here so this is
definitely better than than an if
statement ok harsh it says Jessie please
setup and grub for this project - I'd
love to see the action live last time
alright awesome thank you for suggesting
that I had completely forgotten about it
so I'm definitely going to try to get
that set up as soon as I can
and probably for some of the other
projects I can do it as well so I had
idea for an idea for project 3 so we've
been worked out was the project where we
were working with dotnet framework so my
idea is since we're basically just
working on UI stuff now and then at some
point we're going to hook it up to the
content management system the first
stage where we're just working on the UI
we don't really need it to be in dotnet
framework what we can do is just pull
that out and make it a git repo and just
set it up and run I don't know maybe
we'll just run it with gulp as our as
our task runner and I'll have that on
github and then that way you all can
check out all the code easily on github
I can run the project with an grok you
can see that we don't have to deal with
like manually refreshing things or the
slowness in general of the website so I
think that's what I'm gonna do
so we'll see I have some other project
coming up so hopefully at some point
this week I can get all that set up and
then you all can I mean you all can even
submit pull requests if you want so I
think it'll be a much better way to do
it we can build out everything we want
for all the different templates in there
and then when the time comes we'll just
copy and paste everything in and maybe
pull it out into different components
and try to hook it all up then but it
would be nice to do it like that and
then we can even I can show it to other
people in my department and get feedback
I think it'll be a much tighter like
feedback loop in general if we can do it
like that so that's coming to I'll set
up and drop for that one as well
and that says so you're good with Redux
now let's use the term good loosely and
say that I'm good with Redux right to be
more accurate I have successfully
completed one project with Redux and
that was the the kind of blog projects
that allowed you to do comments and vote
so yeah that was that was my one project
so yes I'd say good in the very very
loose use of the term get shine says
hello sir what does it do redux thunk
and what is reselect library I don't I
don't know what Reis elect libraries
referring to I guess I'm missing that so
if you could clarify more about that
then maybe I can answer you as far as
redux thunk so I just answered a similar
question of that so go ahead and I just
go with what I had what I said there and
that is basically check out the redux
thunk github page and there's some
examples there and a link to more
information so I don't want to I did a
terrible job of trying to explain it a
few minutes ago so I don't want to
attempt it again and throw you off
giving you an explanation that's not
accurate so I just go I'd recommend go
right to the source and that's probably
where you're gonna get the best
information
Kiyoshi says this is my first time here
interesting to see how you do everything
in real time thanks you're welcome
thanks for watching yeah hopefully you
can join us again sometime
Rohan says what youtube 4 times speed is
that extension what extension I don't
know I I don't know how they did it four
times speed but someone
some point said that they watched my
videos in for time speed so yeah I know
YouTube only lets you go to what like to
time speed so it must have been some
sort of extension but I I never asked
what the extension was so if anybody
knows put it in the live chat please or
later on if you're watching the
recording in in the comments all right
Dule says off the topic where can I find
how to use things from materialize in my
code pen projects encode pen you can
import materialize so if you click on
you have to click on where you import
CSS and JavaScript until you want to
import from the from a CDN materialized
JavaScript and their CSS so if you go on
the materialized site under the getting
started tab they should have the the
URLs that you'll need to bring in and
that's how you want to do it so let me
know if if if you're having trouble with
that send me a direct message on Twitter
my Twitter a link to my Twitter account
is in the description this video and I
can I can help you out more but just
from memory I haven't actually used
codepen in a little while but at least
that used to be the way that you would
do it I don't think the UI has changed
or anything so that's just still work ok
so Matt says redux thunk allows you to
dispatch multiple readout to actions
without returning a Taipan value ok
awesome thank you Matt that's that's a
very concise way to explain that so
definitely better than my explanation so
shine again asks then what is reselect
library and making react projects so
again I yeah I don't really know what
reselect is Jake says there's a pretty
good flowchart that everyone recommends
for react redux but can't post links ok
so evidently is a good flowchart out
there
so we don't have the link but maybe it's
hopefully it's not too hard to find so I
know I've seen several different
pictures of it just to get a visual of
the flow which will probably be easier
than my explanation at least for me a
visual is always pretty easy to grasp so
there's I know there's a bunch of them
out there so if you want to kind of dig
deeper and get a better understanding of
redux then you know probably probably
shouldn't take too long to search for
that Harshit says Jessie I have a great
suggestion for you if you are using
prettier use its atom package it has
linting integration and enable format on
submit that is a good suggestion Thanks
you know what I somebody suggested that
before and I just I just never got
around to doing it and just kind of
forgot about it so I'm gonna have to do
that yeah that'll probably be good and
then that way I'll automatically get the
formatting and I won't have to wait for
a commit so that will definitely be
useful so thanks for that
let's see okay so it looks like Matt is
commenting on this reselect library so
this has never used it but it looks like
it aims to reduce redux actions and
Redux reducers into one function oh
that's interesting
okay that's kind of cool I might like to
see that I mean right now I'm just
learning so maybe it's better if I keep
everything separate you know and it'll
be easier to understand based on
tutorials but at some point it it might
clean things up actually to have them
combined
okay so uh Blake says so I ran NPM start
and I can't stop it okay and Matt
respond to just use control-c and that
that works everywhere well at least it
works in linic and max I'm pretty sure
it's the same on Windows but yeah
control see you'll get you out of it
all right Madison use a stateless
function yeah I'll probably I'll go
through and use stateless functions at
some point right now probably gonna end
up having to use stateful functions or I
should say basically using like the
class method if that's what it's called
but you all know what I'm talking about
and react so you know using the class
here so for a lot of these components
I'm going to end up needing this so
later on I can go back through then and
change them into functional components
but at this point I'm thinking that I'll
probably end up needing it like this
okay so control see does work on Windows
we got verification of that alex says
another react project you should do
angular typescript and rxjs or some
serious stuff you know I honestly didn't
even think about that really I since I'm
doing the course on react right now I'm
just kind of like trying to do like I'll
react all the time and just multiply my
gains here on on learning so I'm not
opposed to other things to be honest
with you if I'm gonna do something else
right now I probably try out view I just
a lot of people that I follow on Twitter
seem to be talking about view so I think
I tried that out over angular but I'm
not opposed to it we'll see for for my
work here at the University I would
actually like to use the same thing for
everything just to make it easier to
keep up with and then potentially if we
need to hire more developers just to be
able to like say like this is the skill
set we need and you know instead of
saying like we need somebody that can do
all these different things that are
familiar with all these different
frameworks so probably won't use things
that are too different from react for
these streams but potentially I don't
know it could happen but I can't make
any guarantees about it right now
oh it looks like a few of you also said
view get try view harsh that says what
headphones ease I don't know let me see
I don't really know it doesn't say it
just says the logo it's a SteelSeries so
I got these so long ago I can't remember
I can't remember what they are I could
maybe look back at my Amazon history and
see so I come from Amazon I think they
were around $50 60 L or something like
that I really can't remember because
it's been so long but I like these
headphones they're comfortable I can't
wear these all day and you know my ears
maybe we'll get a little bit sore but
generally like they're they're pretty
good if you're like all about sound
probably you want to get better ones it
does have a retractable mic so I can use
this but it doesn't work with with Mac
so it's just a regular like headphone
jack it doesn't work with a Mac it works
with my android phone as a mic so I
guess keep that in mind I I had kind of
got these before I really started
working with max but so I probably go
with something different I mean I have
another mic for this Mac but it'd be
good to have it maybe like for my laptop
but anyway if anybody's really
interested in what these headphones are
let me know because I'll look it up in
my Amazon purchase history and then I
can get you exactly what information
about exactly what these are now that
I'm actually showing my face on youtube
I was thinking about getting one of
those like ridiculous like gamer
headphones that lights up different
colors and things just so it's a little
bit more interesting I don't know what
do you think do you have any suggestions
let me know huh
all right I'm getting almost to the
bottom here of the live chat okay
somebody mentioned semicolons and Rowan
says they're entirely optional in jazz
yeah so if it looks weird that I'm not
using semicolons it it is weird I mean
it it's definitely weird if you're not
used to seeing it like that but yeah
something you don't need semicolons I
don't want to start any trouble here
because sometimes people get strong
opinions about this whether or not you
should use semicolons I like it I like
not using semicolons to me it's like as
long as the code is still readable and
it works then typing less is better than
typing more so that's how I feel about
it I have heard and I can't remember
exactly when but there are some use
cases where you want the semicolon in
because it doesn't work how do you think
it would but it's been my experience
that's that's rare so I don't know it
just depend on what you're using it for
so if you're thinking about quitting
semicolons then I would check it out
first to see in what cases you shouldn't
do it and then see if those cases ever
come up for you and if they don't then
you know they'd get rid of the
semicolons but yeah I don't for my
projects I don't like semicolons but it
doesn't bother me if other people use
semicolons
see
okay so James Henderson had a follow-up
before he had mentioned to let him know
if you need I needed help with the
single sign-on stuff so he said it's
somewhat easy it depends on the product
I've also tested SSO single sign-on that
is where there are some fun times as a
service for the dev team so alright so
evidently it does that makes a lot of
sense of defense on the product I mean
that's okay that's what I my experience
with let's several other things as well
James also says the only dumb question
is the question you don't ask and that
is sometimes the only way you learn
please don't take that as being rude I
always learn from the videos yeah it
definitely that's so if anybody's right
now watching and you got a question you
know I'm sure if you should ask it ask
it don't worry about it just ask the
question and as long as it's not like
something really offensive I'm gonna
answer it
so certainly anything developer related
ah-ho-ho answer for sure so yeah but any
don't think the questions to like
beginner or anything like that like I'm
not gonna make fun of anybody for any
questions although if you've been on
watching for a long time and I I might
be able to get away with making fun of
you let me know if you don't like that
though but there's some of you that have
been watching for so long on a live
stream I feel like we have enough of a
relationship that we could joke but if
you're new I will not nobody's gonna
make fun of you and if they do I will
tell them not to Blake says what is here
he asked what is the best free course on
react and or inexpensive courses hmm
about courses code Academy has react
stuff that's free I think it's pretty
good for basics for starting out I think
other than that I pretty much just
watched YouTube videos for react stuff
and just read I didn't really do a
course and the Udacity course I'm
obviously doing but it's not inexpensive
I guess it depends on what would you
consider inexpensive - yes I don't know
that I have any other suggestions that
I've used personally
kevin says Jesse what is your opinion on
functional programming JavaScript is
somewhat compatible with this paradigm
and react Redux are based on functional
programming principles I think you also
mentioned currying yeah yes I mentioned
currying we were talking about like this
stuff down here as currying so and I
think I said I'm not going to attempt to
explain currying right now because I
don't think I could do a great job at it
so you could check out you know search
currying and it's not really a complex
thing I just would rather not mess up
your understanding if this is the first
time you heard about it so yeah in terms
of functional programming from what I've
read about it I guess I like it
that's weird to say as compared to like
object-oriented programming I honestly
do think it makes sense with JavaScript
all right I don't really think that I'm
at a point where I can have really a
really informed opinion about it so I
guess I can't I don't feel like I have
enough knowledge about things to really
make a call like one way or another all
I can say is that from what I understand
I think I would prefer it to
object-oriented stuff with JavaScript so
let's see I just got a message from my
boss so I'm gonna have to wrap this up
quickly because he wants me to go to his
office
so Kevin so we're at authorization
whatever you want yeah that that was the
actual example for the projects I just
stuck with it
Harshit says any plans on graph QL yeah
I'd love to use graph QL at some point
not sure when but I would definitely
want to
Rowland says the SteelSeries Siberia 100
yeah I think that's it for the
headphones
Blake's has thoughts on react license
change I was pleasantly surprised by it
so I wasn't that worried about the old
license for me personally but I I do I
like the move I think I think it's good
for react and it's definitely good for
developers not a legal expert though so
that's my my uneducated opinion let's
see
see
all right let me alright so if I missed
your your question I'm really sorry
about that you can ask me on Twitter or
in the comments but my boss is messaging
me on slack several times now so I need
to go in there and see what's up
and anyway thank you so much for
watching
she'd be back tomorrow around 2 p.m.
Eastern Time and until then have a great
day